- Hi everyone and welcome
to the Khan Academy
"Daily Homeroom" Live Stream
for those y'all who are wondering
what this is.
And this is something
that we started when we started
seeing the school closures really around
the world as a way to stay connected
and have interesting conversations
about things related to
the crisis education,
or just frankly, interesting conversations
before we get into today's conversation,
which will I promise to be interesting.
I'm using that word a lot right now.
I do wanna make a special shout out
to several corporations that stepped up.
We are not for profit.
We only exist through
philanthropic donations.
We were running at a deficit
even before the crisis,
and now our server costs have gone up.
We're trying to accelerate
a bunch of programs.
So special thanks the Bank of America,
Google.org, AT&T, Fastly
and Novartis for stepping
up really in record time
and helping us close that gap.
We do continue to run a deficit.
So with any donation,
even a $3, $5 donation,
those add up, and that's
what allows Khan Academy
to do what we do and make
it free and noncommercial
and accessible to students
all over the world
and teachers and parents
all over the world.
So with that said, I'm eager
to introduce our guest,
Angela Duckworth, Angela how are you?
- I'm fine, Sal, how are you?
- I'm doing all right.
And Angela, you are,
you have the distinction
of being our first repeat guest,
on the live stream.
- I'm so excited.
I hope I don't blow it.
- That must be based on something
that we don't just do that willy-nilly.
- Okay I'll take it
as a compliment.
- So.
(laughing)
it is a complement.
So for those of y'all, who did not
see the first episode with
Angela a few weeks ago,
Angela is really one of the world leaders
on talking about mindset
and particular grit
and how grit relates to
thingS like resilience
and growth mindset.
And so you can imagine
in this COVID socially distance world,
we're all living in
where we're trying to figure out
how to keep people motivated.
How do we keep learning?
And that is how do we deal with everything
going on with our lives?
Angela is a really interesting person
to talk with and we have
a bunch of questions
already from our last session
that I hope to get to some of them,
but for any of y'all
on Facebook or YouTube,
feel free to add questions.
And we have team members
of Khan Academy who
are gonna be surfacing
them to myself and Angela,
but Angela, maybe a good place to start.
You know, last time we talked
a lot about growth mindset and grit,
and it's kind of this, you know,
you can easily get into this view that
like look, if you have a
growth mindset, you fail,
you hit some adversity,
you just keep chipping away at it.
And eventually you'll
get to the other side.
But how does that equate
with the other notion
that, you know, not everyone
has the same starting point,
not everyone the same
tools at their disposal.
So how do you, how do you, you know,
there's growth mindset
and grit and resilience
and then there's equity, really?
Yeah, I have lately been, not just lately.
I have been reading criticism of my work
and also Carol Dweck
work on growth mindset.
And when I get past the
natural human reaction,
which is total defensiveness
and I really listen,
I hear something that's really valuable.
And I think the critiques are
that if you talk about grit, resilience,
and growth mindset and character,
it sounds like it's all about the kid.
It's all about the student
and the entire burden of responsibility
falls on their shoulders.
And there's no mention
of equity and poverty,
lack of opportunity, you
know, massive differences
that we're all well aware exist,
not only in our country,
but around the world.
And I think the reconciliation is this.
It is not that these you
know, ideas about mindset
and learning and grit
are, I think at odds with,
you know, it's not an either or
like it's either the situation or
it's the person it's both and.
And you know, very
briefly I'll just say so
that in psychology, there was like a war
between people in psychology,
psychological researchers
who thought that, you know,
so much of our behavior was about
our personality and who we were.
Then there were the other psychologists
who said, no, it's really
about the situation.
And the war is over because
really everyone recognizes
that they both matter.
I was once in a classroom,
in a public school
that shall remain nameless,
but these two boys were
sitting at their desk.
All the other kids were doing their work.
They were all on these laptops, you know,
pounding away at some assigned activity.
These two kids were doing nothing.
Now, if you walked in,
just at that moment,
you would say, well, those
two kids don't have grit.
Those two kids are doing
nothing, but I walked
in actually before the bell rang.
And I saw all the students walk up
to the laptop cart and these two boys
were last in line and they
got the two broken laptops.
They couldn't do anything all period
because they lacked opportunity.
And I think that's the mistake
that I see critics not wanting to make,
not to mistake, lack of
opportunity for lack of grit.
And I, you know, have to say
that I completely agree with that.
That's stoplight.
And your example's a good one.
If you've got the broken laptop, I mean,
that's an extreme example.
Of course you're not gonna be able
to even apply your grit
or your growth mindset.
And it is fascinating how in many times
in academic circles people
can get into these religious calves,
but it's clearly not one of the other
to your point that
environment and opportunity
for sure is gonna make a difference,
but whatever set of cards you are dealt,
if you are able to approach
that with a growth mindset,
given that context,
you're gonna get further, all else equal.
That's not to say that
if two kids don't get
to a certain place or the same place
that you can somehow blame
the kid who didn't get there
on their lack of mindset,
it might've been other things.
It might've been a context.
So yeah, it makes, it makes all the sense
in the world to me on
that, I mean you know,
just double clicking on that a little bit,
there's a question from Facebook
Richie Getler asks.
And I think a lot of
parents are wondering this
for at least one of their children.
How do you help inspire a kid who wants
to practice to want to practice something?
Is it essential that we simply do things
we like to do in order to be successful?
And we touched on about that a little bit
in our last conversation, but yeah.
How do you motivate someone to practice
maybe something that is not obvious
that they love it, or
do you just say, well,
only do the things that you love
or how can you learn to love things?
- You know, since our last conversation,
which is now a few weeks ago,
so I've been thinking about what you said
in that part of the conversation,
which is, you said that
pretty much anything
can become fascinating to you.
And when you need to record a video,
you'd like, you don't record
until you can become fascinated,
but, but gosh, like what couldn't be,
you know what would fall
outside of that category?
And I've been thinking about it
because I wonder whether for you
as like who you are
your core as a teacher.
And so what excites you is as being able
to understand something
and then being able
to teach it and communicate it.
You can certainly tell me,
but let me respond first
to that question directly.
I think that when kids are
starting out in something
that the, the thing to emphasize
is interest and enjoyment.
And to wait a little bit if you can,
to impose, you know, the hardest,
most challenging repetitive
kind of practice.
And that is because until
a child gets engaged in something,
it's a very romantic period.
In fact, some scientists use the term,
the romantic period to describe that
initial kind of flirtation.
Like you kind of have a joy
to what you're doing,
and then you love it so much
that you can evolve into somebody
who's willing to do more drills
more like really hard stuff.
Now with school, something
Sal that you have much more
experience with than I do.
You might say that, you know,
for math for example, something,
I know that, you know
Khan Academy all started.
It's not necessarily like,
if you think yourself like, well,
when is this romantic you gonna come?
Because you know, my kid
really doesn't love it.
I think that even
if you could just take
it as a principle, right?
Like how much enjoyment and interest
and fun can there be,
maybe it won't be as fun
as, you know Minecraft,
but like the more, the better,
and the earlier you
are in your development
as a learner, the more you
really need that I think.
Yeah the way I think you are right.
I realized that my mindset
towards certain things,
maybe isn't as mainstream as,
as we would like that we would all,
you know, I can get excited about
almost anything, you know,
this weekend you know,
I'm Swiffer you know
wet Swiffering the house
and I'm fascinated by it.
(laughing)
(mumbles)
Yeah I love it, I love it.
So, you know I do try to convince myself
that if there's something I'm gonna do,
I might as well enjoy it.
I might as well appreciate
what I'm gonna get out of it.
And, you know, a good example,
you know, kids for the most part,
don't complain if they're working out
at the gym and they
gotta run on a treadmill
for 30 minutes, or you know they're trying
to weight lift,
and they're doing these
really weird exercises
that work on their forearms
or something like that,
because they know that it's all,
well first of all, they
oftentimes will enjoy it.
'Cause they're like,
hey, I'm working on something,
I'm building a habit.
That's going to make me better
in some way more prepared
for battle with the world
or understand the world,
or be able to engage with the world
in a stronger way.
So that's my gut sense
is that the more people
just appreciate that,
the more that even some of the, you know,
little hairy things that you have
to deal with in academics,
you can kinda power through them.
'Cause you're like, "oh, this
is gonna make me better."
At being a holistic person,
you know, my son is,
you know takes piano lessons
and he loves playing piano and famously.
When you play piano, you
have to practice your scales
- Right
- And scales in a vacuum.
You know, just going up and down there,
that's obviously not composing.
You're obviously not gonna make friends
at a party by just playing your scales.
It might not be particularly that fun.
But when you recognize that by building
that muscle memory and getting better
and better at your skills
and even professional pianist
practice their scales,
it, the is actually kind of become fun
and become interesting.
And you know, you're becoming
better every time you do them.
- Yeah and I think you're
reminding us so that,
you know, what's interesting and fun.
Isn't just objectively
what the activity is.
There are piano teachers,
I specifically know of one named Cindy Lam
in Pasadena, California,
who makes scales fun.
She makes games out of them.
Her students actually enjoy doing scale.
So it's not just like, is it enjoyable
or not enjoyable, but it's in
a way like how it's framed.
You know, one thing
that makes things really boring
for kids is when we don't give
them a purpose or a point to it,
like do this worksheet, do this.
Why?
Just do it.
You're not giving the student
any reason to feel like this activity
is connected to any larger goal.
And actually there is a science of boredom
and one of the ways things
can be bored and boring is because
it lacks any obvious purpose.
Another, and I actually just wrote
about this and I actually
mentioned Khan Academy
specifically as an antidote to this.
So one other way to be bored.
So I just said, one way to be bored
is like, what's the point of this?
Another way to be bored if
things are too easy or too hard.
And either of those create
the psychology of boredom
and the reason I mentioned Khan Academy
and this little essays,
is because I think this is
why among other reasons,
Khan Academy is so great
because it allows students to self
kind of calibrate and also
through your backend algorithms
to deliver to students like
what they need in their sweet spot.
But anyway, as as
parents and as educators,
I think the principle is, you know,
can you make things more
enjoyable and interesting.
Can you you know give
kids the bigger picture?
Like this is why we're
doing these pushups,
or this is why we're doing scales.
And also can you calibrate?
So the things are neither
too easy nor too hard.
- Yeah and I have to remind
myself that all the time.
I mean, especially with,
I've talked to others livestream,
our older too in my 11
year old and eight year old
have for the most part
have been quite good in
this socially distance,
remote learning, whatever
you wanna call it world
they've been, but our five-year-old
has been difficult and it's very easy
to fall into that frustrated parent trap
of like, look, you just need
to do this one worksheet.
You just need to do this one exercise
and it, you know.
But they kinda get entrenched
because and then if you just,
and then, and then you both escalate
(laughing)
at some point, you're like
giving them a time out.
- Yes frequently.
- 'Cause they're, they're screaming at you
or they, you know,
and I've had to learn some oftentimes
the hard way you just have to sometimes
take a step back and say,
"okay, how do I put this
"in a context that in this case,
"my youngest, my son will have fun.
"Like, can we turn this into a game?"
Does it not fit even a five-year-old
will rebel if they feel
like they're being forced
or coerced versus if they
are invested in the project.
And even if they don't see, you know,
they, you know, it's hard
to convince a five-year-old
that like, "hey, by writing better,
"you know you're gonna have
"this ability to communicate in the world
"and you're gonna have to do
that the rest of your life."
But even even just to say, you know,
it's building a muscle, it's fun.
It's a game.
I think, I think is a start.
So one thing I forgot to introduce you
but people saw you all
your title on the screen is
that you have started
something called the Character Lab.
And many people here have asked about
it from YouTube.
Sean Numba what is Character Lab?
James Lou question for Angela,
a bit about Resources and Character Lab.
Arcade Jack, what is Character Lab?
So people wanna know Angela,
what is Character Lab?
- Thank you for those three questions
because I'm so in love with Character Lab.
It's a nonprofit I
started with two educators
and its mission is to
advance scientific insights
that help kids thrive.
Now character is a word that Aristotle
and Maria Montessori and
Martin Luther King use.
But I think commonly it's called
social, emotional learning
or 21st century skills,
call it whatever you want.
The list is the list that all parents
and educators want kids to develop
gratitude and curiosity,
empathy, social intelligence,
grit, growth mindset.
There's a science behind
any of those things
that I mentioned.
And I think the idea that
we're living in exciting times,
that rather than just
sermonizing to our kids
about these things, that
we hope they'll develop,
we can actually draw on
random assignment experiments
that, you know, show how
to improve growth mindset
and ditto for gratitude, et cetera.
So if you go to that website,
it's all like Khan Academy,
philanthropically supported.
So if you are a parent or
an educator in particular,
I hope that you find, you know,
direct dialing scientists
through this website as it were.
Because every word on that website
is written by a scientist,
not by an intermediary.
- And I highly recommended it,
we've used the work at Character Lab.
I look at it sometimes I reference myself.
As family and you know we
have a Lab School we started
and we've leveraged a lot
of the work at Character Lab
to think about,
'Cause one of the things we
try to do with the Lab School
is not just kids are
developing academically,
but social emotional development
is a very explicit part.
And we've used a lot of the
taxonomies and frameworks
from the character lab to think about,
how do we even, you know,
what dimensions matter
and how do we even measure
or think about measuring
some of these things?
So from YouTube, we have a teacher here,
Daniel Kinross asks,
"how can teachers encourage grit
"during remote learning
"with students out of reach.
"It seems easier than ever
for students to give up."
- Ah this is this is a question
that is near and dear to my heart.
I have an 18 year old and
a 17 year old at home.
Little, a little bit farther
down the track than you.
So in terms of how old my kids are,
but you know, when there's
not only distance learning,
but there's also this
like very blurry line
between morning, afternoon,
and evening between weekday and weekend.
It's just very easy for like suddenly
like nine days to slip away
and like nothing really got done.
So it's a terrific question.
I think the person that
I've turned to the most
during this distance learning
period for wisdom is Ron Berger.
And so you know, the
expeditionary learning schools
and Ron in particular as
the chief academic officer
at such a siege on these things.
And I think what his advice would be
is to actually take the
opportunity of distance learning
and this, you know, enforced strangeness
that we have as educators.
And, and use it to move more aggressively
toward project-based learning.
Toward things where like, you know,
it's not just like, do this worksheet
or fill out this thing.
It's like, we have a project,
like we're gonna try to
figure out, you know,
how to you know,
make like recycling work
in this neighborhood,
or you could do something
it's very, COVID specific.
Like there are lots of, you know,
older people in our neighborhood.
How can we take on as a project?
Like getting them, their groceries.
Now, some of the stuff you're thinking,
like how does this have to,
you know, what does it have
to do with like reading,
writing and arithmetic?
And I think there, it's not easy
to like always draw the line,
but that's the challenge.
In other words, when you do
projects that are authentic,
you do have to do a little
more work as an educator
to think how you're
going to integrate some
of the basic skills that
we need students to learn.
But the tilt I think is really powerful
because when you do have a project
that you're excited about,
you're not like dragging yourself
out of bed to force yourself to do it.
You're excited to do it.
And you're kind of about it,
frankly, like all the time.
So to learn more, I think
if you Google expeditionary learning
and Ron Berger, you'll find
that he's writing a lot
of wise things right now.
- And you bring up an
interesting point here.
We talked about these kind of camps,
these dogmatic camps that sometimes form
and academic circles before
we were talking about.
You know, is it about context and equity
or is it more about mindset?
And to your point, it's not an either or
it's both matter.
And you know, I've seen a similar
'cause we were talking about
project-based learning.
I've seen a similar
type of dogmatic battle
in education circles where there's,
I guess you could say the traditionalist,
who would say "no, you've
gotta learn those skills.
"You gotta learn, you
know, practice your scales,
"so to speak before you
become a great pianist."
- Yeah.
- And then you would have
the more you could say,
progressive educators, project
based oriented program.
Who're like, no, you should
start composing on day one.
So it becomes interesting.
(laughing)
But, but what I heard you say is
it still is a bit of a boat.
You shouldn't go,
you shouldn't, it's not all or nothing
on one side or the other.
- Yeah, absolutely.
You know, both there,
there is pretty much the
answer to so many questions.
And I think that is because
there are trade offs, right?
And in project-based learning,
you get certain advantages.
But you know, maybe you don't get the,
you know, super you know,
densely packed, like you know,
repetitive skill part right.
But then when you just do that,
then you maybe lose a little bit
of the intrinsic
motivation and the purpose.
And you were just talking about how
that can be really demotivating.
So I think with project based learning
and maybe more traditional instruction,
I mean, I'm not, I'm not a expert
or veteran educator,
but it does seem to me
that they are complimentary
and when you see the best schools
and the best classrooms and frankly like,
you know, just the best
learning environments
more generally there,
there tends to be both rigor and autonomy.
There tends to be, you
know, both creative projects
and like a systematic approach.
And this is again why it's not easy to do,
but I do think it's what
we're all aiming for.
- Yeah, completely agree.
You know, just using a sports analogy.
If you're a football player,
you obviously have to
practice playing football.
Like you have to play in games
like that are real games
- Yeah.
- And that's kind of the projects
but you'll also do
sprints and weightlifting
and, you know, drills
catching or throwing a ball,
you know, you know, just
different random exercises
that feel a little bit,
and you you'll perfect those exercises.
And once again, if you just did that,
you'd be like, what's the point.
But when you know that, hey,
this is making me more prepared
for a game and I may or may
not use some of these skills
in a given game,
but it's useful toolkit
for the rest of my life.
Then all of a sudden that
too can be motivating.
And that's what I tell kids.
I was like, look, you know,
I'm not sure whether you're gonna have to
use this method for factoring a quadratic
at in some point in the next five years.
I am genuinely not sure,
but I am sure that understanding this
is gonna be, you can build on it
so that you can learn
things like statistics.
You can learn things like trigonometry
and I can't tell you how many areas.
I mean, statistics, you're
talking about a project,
almost any project,
if you wanna do it legitimately
at a kind of a impact, the world level
statistics is gonna be a piece of that.
You know, almost anything
that you're making,
designing, creating
trigonometry, geometry,
and some basic level of algebra
is gonna be a part of it.
Anything you do in this world,
being able to have reasonable
reading comprehension
and writing capability is going to be
kind of table stakes in this world.
So it's good to make sure
that you don't have
that one spelling error
that you noticed, you're like,
wow, what is you know this?
Is he literate?
(all laughing)
Which I'm guilty of sometimes
I always blame it on typos, but
(all laughing)
So typing too fast
- So great though
like having that conversation in a,
in a like, you know,
sometimes people ask me like,
well, how old your kids need to be
before you can talk to them at a level
of sophistication about, you know,
some of these issues, like the,
the metacognition is a too
beyond them to like, you know,
really understand why
they're doing this thing.
Why am I?
And I'm like, it's pretty
much never too young,
honestly, like, just start.
I mean, you know, kids
are smarter than you,
so go you know, don't use jargon.
If hey don't understand.
Try to explain it another way.
But I think, you know, one of
the big changes in education,
I wonder if you agree Sal
is, well, I hope it's a
change in education is that,
you know, we're I'm not saying
that like the student and the teacher
are interchangeable and there's no reason
why we even have to, I'm not saying that.
I'm just saying that students
are remarkably perceptive
and intelligent and they can
understand when you say like,
this is why we're doing this.
Like the, you know, the scope and sequence
looks like this.
And like, we have to
get through this part.
So you can get to this
part if you don't get
this part, you know?
So I think they're not too young
to understand any of those things.
And we should never assume
that they're too young
to understand those things.
We should always at
least try to communicate
to them, like the why
of what they're doing.
- I agree, 100%.
I think it's so easy for us to assume
where five, six, seven, eight year olds,
you know, that they don't think
about how the world works, but they do.
And if you talk to them about jobs
and the competitive workplace
and how, and what skills you need
to be able to participate, it's funny.
I think there was this was many years ago.
It was like five or six years ago.
I got an email from a mother
and she had a picture of her child
and he was working like diligent.
It was a seven year old
I've I felt that so.
There was some interview like this,
where I was talking
about the future of work
and that you know,
the future of work is gonna be defined
by our ability to keep learning.
That you're not just
gonna have a set of skills
that you can apply until
you get your pension.
That automation and even some you know,
it was gonna make labor.
- Artificial intelligence right.
- Artificial intelligence,
- Yeah.
- Robotics, so you wanna
be able to participate
at the top of that pyramid
in the knowledge economy
and get many as many people there.
And so this mother I guess saw
that interview with
her seven year old son.
And then immediately after that interview,
he went to his room and like,
she didn't see him for another hour.
And like, she went in the room,
she was what are you doing?
He's like, I'm done
working on Khan Academy
and he's, he she's like, "why?
He's like, "I need to make sure
"I don't get economically marginalized."
(all laughing)
I think he use words like almost
economically marginalized.
So clearly a precocious kid
using words like that at age seven.
But he said something that felt like
I wanna make sure that I don't get like,
you know, automated out of the economy.
So he definitely understood.
And that, that's kind of
that I remember there's, you know,
I'm dating myself, I'm, you know,
there's a Karl Malone quote,
famous basketball player
for the Utah Jazz.
And he used to imagine, he used to say,
"whenever I get tired,
"I imagine that my
competitors are at the gym."
And I don't want that
to be like, you know,
to stress people out,
that you have to always
be like on top of it.
But that can also be a
little bit of a motivator
that like, you know look
it's, you don't want your
kids to get stressed out,
but you also don't want them to live
in a reality where they think that,
you know, actually I see this,
the fire I grew up not so wealthy.
So I had a little bit
of a fire in my belly.
'Cause, you know, I could say, look,
I wanna different standard of living.
- I dint know that.
- Oh yeah you know my mom,
- I didn't know that yeah
- Oh no my mum you know,
we were, you know she raised us by herself
and she was a cashier at
some convenient stores.
And you know,
so she was the year I
went to apply to college.
She was making 16,000 a year.
But that, you know for me, that created
kind of a little bit
of a fire in my belly.
You know, I would see friends
whose parents were doctors
and engineers and lawyers.
I was like, that's a good life.
They're living in a nice house.
They are able to go on vacations.
They go to restaurants, they
don't reuse paper towels.
Like that's the life I want.
I still reuse paper
towels every now and then,
but that's the life I want.
But you know, you oftentimes worry about,
I think kids who grow up middle class
or even upper middle
class, they kinda say,
"'Cause my parents did this,
this must be kinda easy.
"This is just the way it is."
But then they, they later get a bit
of a rude awakening that
know the world sometimes
can be a pretty, you know, these jobs
just don't fall in your lap.
That you, you need to prepare for them.
And they're, there are kids
with that fire in their belly
who are preparing for
it from a very young age
because they, you know, they
see the reason at an early age.
They say, wow if I stay on track
with my studies and
graduate from high school
and do well in college.
I can live over there
and I can go on vacations
and I can support my family.
And if I don't,
I might be living under
financial stress for,
for a very, very, very long time.
And you know, to your
earlier point about equity,
it's not like it's just
all about the kids mindset.
It for sure is a lot about support.
You know, even though I
didn't grow up, particularly
that well off, I had a lot of support.
You know I had supports from
teachers who believed in me
and who took extra attention with me.
I had, I was exposed to people
who did make it that way.
So I was able to even see
that side of the world.
But yeah, it's it is fascinating
how we can kinda keep that,
keep that motivation
by letting people know
a little bit about the
reality of the world,
but without them getting
too stressed about it.
(laughing)
- Yeah, absolutely.
And, you know, use your judgment.
But I, I think one of the three lines
of what you're saying,
and what I agree with is that,
you know, kids don't need to
be like sheltered from like
my dad who was not so great at,
you know, thinking about
how to talk to kids.
He'd like, just talk to
me like I was an adult
and that wasn't always great,
but it mostly was right.
So, you know, I learned
about supply and demand
and I learned about his
particular view of the economy
and I learned about thermodynamics.
And anyway, I think
kids are so much smarter
and so much more ready than
we often give them credit for.
And if we try, we can have conversations
with them about, you know, what
it means to be marginalized
in the knowledge economy.
And maybe we can find words
that are like a little
more intuitive for them,
but it doesn't mean we shouldn't
try to have those conversations.
- I think I'm a little bit like your dad,
I'm guilty of actually all my kids,
like all of the lullabies I sing to them,
are like classic rock songs
that I happen to have the lyrics for.
So like my kids, like my,
their nighttime lullaby,
like just last night for Azov who's five
and a 1/2 year old,
I sing "Hotel California" with him.
- You are to (mumbles) yourself.
- He like, He's like, what does it mean
that her mind is Tiffany twisted?
What's our Mercedes-Benz
(all laughing)
what's colitis.
Why does it have a warm smell?
- And so.
- By the way, you can explain
to me the "Hotel California,"
then maybe, maybe I could listen in
'cause like, I obviously don't know.
- It's a deep song.
(mumbles)
or is it figurative?
You can, you can check
out anytime you like,
but you just can never leave.
- Exactly.
- That's led to a lot of
conversations with my kids.
What does it mean to check
out, but not to leave?
- Leave good well,
if you ever get to a really
succinct you know explanation,
like an unpacking of
the "Hotel California,"
I would appreciate that 'cause now.
- Yeah.
- I'm still.
- There's a few times
when I have to kind of,
you know, my five year old is like,
why do they stab it with
their steely knives?
And what beast are they trying to kill?
And I'm like, no, let's stop.
Let's not go there right now.
- Okay time for bed.
- Time for bed.
Why aren't you asleep?
(all laughing)
- Okay, so here's a good
question from Facebook,
Steven Cottrell, before
people start getting
on my horrible parenting habits.
So from Steven Cottrell,
what are tips on developing
a sense of purpose
among teenagers?
Great question.
- You know, one of the,
like, like less known,
but I think really important facts
about adolescents is that,
you know, teenagers are
maybe more purpose driven
during that period of
life than any other time.
And so we have a stereotype
of teenagers being selfish
and even narcissistic
and really to the contrary,
they're extremely motivated
by fairness by equity,
by social change.
I witnessed this myself with
my own 17 and 18 year old.
I often get with mini lectures
on how I have to, I think,
like, I think of myself as someone
who's like reasonably feminist.
And like they, they update
me and correct me when they
think that that's needed.
So then the question is how do we channel
all that adolescent, you know,
purpose driven motivation.
And I think one real challenge
this particular summer
is that a lot of things that
I would typically suggest
like volunteer for this,
or if you know, do that
are you know, those are foreclosed.
So it's gonna take a
little more creativity
and proactivity the summer
to channel purpose
appropriately for teenagers.
One thing that I just heard of
is that there are now,
I'll send you the links Sal.
You know, it's not, it's not perfect,
but honestly I think it's still great.
Ways for teenagers to tutor younger kids
all throughout the summer.
As you well know, Sal,
what the pandemic has done,
is not only should shine the
light on a lack of equity,
but also increased lack of equity.
And I think there are a lot of people,
including you and me
who are terrified at the learning losses,
particularly for less advantaged kids.
So if you've got a purpose
driven teenager in the house
I'll send some links over for ways
that they could plug in as, as tutors.
And one of the silver linings is like,
it doesn't matter where you live.
Like you can find a kid
who's in your time zone.
And you know, a starfish theory, right?
Like prevent at least one child
from falling behind this year.
- Yeah I'll just doubly
underline what you just said,
you know, for any teenager or any young
or any person who says, "you know,
"what do I do with myself right now?"
There's never been an in
at least in our lifetimes,
a bigger opportunity where,
even a very young person
from their bedroom
could actually do a lot
of good in the world.
To your point, you could
tutor other people,
you know, you could
start a new organization
that connects with maybe elderly
who are living by themselves,
or just people who are
living by themselves
helps with mental health issues.
And all of these things are set up
to be able to do remotely.
And if you need to get out of the house,
you know, getting groceries for folks.
Especially elderly,
being able to do services
for them, you know,
help with their gardens.
You can, any teenager any
a young person out there,
if you brainstorm for half an hour,
you're going to think of
30 really fascinating ways
that you can really support
a lot of folks right now so.
- I've heard of (mumbles)
who are like writing
their cell phone number
on a piece of paper
and then just like shoving
it in mail slots, right.
And by the way, as you might imagine,
like not all the elderly
are heavily into texting
or, you know, any other,
so just like saying, call me.
(laughing)
Call me this is where I live.
I would love to like pick up groceries
or go to the pharmacy for you.
Yeah, like you said Sal
like when you just sit down
and start to make a list, like, you know,
you realize that there's so much to do.
And I think actually that's when teenagers
are happiest when they're being useful.
And it's, again, the antidote
to the kind of despair
that I think a lot of teenagers
are feeling like a, you
know an aimlessness mess
and like, "oh, all these
things are taken from me."
But when you start going out
and spending most of your day,
helping other people,
like all of that, basically evaporates.
- Yeah I think there's another theme here,
which is, you know, there's this thing
like teenage angst and
they're in rebellion.
And my belief is that that comes from
the fact that they are proto-adults,
that in most of human history,
they actually would be kind
of on the hunting parties.
They would be helping out with
all of the different things
that the village has to take care of
and the cooking, the cleaning,
the teaching, the hunting, the fighting,
whatever it might be.
But in our modern society.
And we would do it in a multiple,
multiple age groups, you know,
- Yes.
- They would be with uncles
and their cousins and their aunts.
And but now we group them into these very,
you know, fairly narrow age bands.
And they only, we tell them to
only worry about themselves.
- So bizarre, its not weird.
- Your GPA, your scores,
your college admissions,
your extracurriculars,
that's where the (mumbles)
comes from.
- Rank order you.
- Exactly we're gonna rank order you.
- So bizarre.
I mean, for most of human history,
it's actually ways that people,
people, people, kids included,
ran around and multi-age packs,
the five-year-olds or
with the seven year olds,
the seven year olds with the 12 year olds.
And by the way, when you
see kids who are five, seven
and 12, you spontaneously see,
or you see spontaneous
like collaboration, right.
12 year olds take care of seven year old,
seven year olds take
care of five-year-olds.
Now we're in this really weird Era
where we're like, let's
take 1,000, 15 year olds
and put them together.
So they spend all their time
and then we're gonna
rank order them, right.
So you're just competing with each other.
- And they have no tangible responsibility
other than these abstract.
Like.
- Yeah.
- I believe you have to
learn all this stuff.
Obviously I'm a big believer.
You've gotta learn your biology
your chemistry or writing your reading,
your math.
- So abstract, so rude right.
- But it's all abstract.
And it's all about their
own performance in it.
It isn't about a collective.
It isn't about making them.
And to your point, they
are the most idealistic.
I mean, you know, part
of the reason, you know,
a lot of soldiers and things
are on the younger side.
Obviously your body is
very physically able there,
but these are some of the
more idealistic people.
And, you know in history.
- Yeah.
- Sometimes people have taken
not so great advantage of that,
but they believe that change can happen
and they want the adventures in the world.
They don't wanna just kind of fall
into the day to day grind.
And so, yeah 100% agree with you.
Well, whenever we chat Angela,
the time goes by very, very fast.
(laughing)
So maybe, maybe give time for one.
- One more, one more yeah.
- Yeah, do you have time for one more?
- I have time for one more, yes.
- Okay, sounds good.
Let's see, let me find a good one.
There's are all great so this is hard.
(mumbles)
- We have let's see.
- I'm glad your thinking.
(laughing)
- So there's a couple of questions here.
You know, I'll group these together.
- Okay.
- Carly Inkstrom, what do
you think is the best way
to teach kids to break
down their own large tasks?
And by extension all of us to break down,
we're talking a big problem.
You wanna solve loneliness.
How do solve you know,
to our earlier point,
you know, from YouTube, Audrey Omari,
are there any strategies
that you recommend
for staying on task to be productive?
And then Brielle Lee asked,
how can you connect the lack of motivation
towards online learning
with staying at home?
I've noticed that many
struggle to stay on task.
So you had just any parting thoughts
on how do you break things down,
stay motivated, stay
on task, stay focused.
- So I'll just give one suggestion.
And that is this intuition that you have,
the big thing it needs to be
broken up into small things
is exactly right.
And there was research actually
not very far away from
where Sal Khan lives
by Al Bandura at Stanford.
Now many years ago
where he actually had
elementary school kids
who were learning math
and in one condition,
they had to learn a lot of math
and another condition,
He, all he did was he
helped break down the math,
the same math into sub
goals, into smaller parts.
And there was a dramatic benefit
and those kids did better.
And I think the life
lesson, as you say Sal
not only for kids, but for us
is that when you have big things,
you break them into small things.
And when you take those small things
and you break them even further,
that's when I think you
really get momentum.
And I'll just give one personal example.
The hardest thing I
ever did professionally
was to write my book.
And when I thought about
like writing a book,
it was like too big.
Then I thought like, well,
I'll just work on chapter one
still too big.
Then I thought like, well,
just work on like the
first half of chapter one
still too big.
And I found myself procrastinating
and just never feeling like
I wanted to get started.
Then finally I broke it
down to the smallest things
like today, I'm gonna
write a sentence maybe.
And what I meant by maybe is that like
I might throw out that sentence
and now I had broken
down the big thing a book
into smaller things a chapter
into smaller smarts.
So that the thing that I
had to do that day was tiny.
And actually, I think
that was a great strategy
because once I wrote that sentence,
I was like, well since I'm sitting here,
I may as well write another one.
And in general, I think
if we can help kids
learn the skill of breaking down the big,
into small and getting started,
then we'll be actually a long way
towards helping them
finish what they begin.
- Yeah I couldn't agree more.
You know, I that's,
that's a lot of my narrative too,
if you know, just so these tasks
that you can take 1/2 an
hour, hour tip away at them,
but then you look back on it,
you're like, oh, there was a lot.
(laughing)
- Yeah, it adds up, it's
better than nothing,
which is basically what
happens when you procrastinate
is that then you're doing nothing.
- Right just get moving, just get moving.
So Angela, thank you so much.
I mean, there continue to be
so many great questions coming in.
But yeah, thank you for all
the research you've done
and helping us think
about how we can ourselves
have more grit and how we can think about
working with our children
to get that going.
- Thank you Sal I so
enjoyed this conversation.
- Likewise.
So thank you everyone
for joining as always
Angela Duckworth has you
know both informative
and entertaining
and always a pleasure to chat with
about all topics.
And we have several
other really interesting
folks coming on.
We're gonna have Tom
Friedman later this week,
just talking about the
world and this COVID world.
We'll we're gonna have Stu
Schmill from MIT Admissions
to talk about how our college admissions
or even the nature of college
may be changing because of this crisis.
And we have many, many more guests
over the next couple of weeks.
So look forward to seeing y'all
and don't forget, we are not for profit
if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making
a donation to Khan Academy.
Thanks everyone.